Saudi Arabia's top prosecutor has just
announced new charges in last month's
killing of washing Post contributor
Jamal khashoggi he wants five of the
suspects to face the death penalty for
the killing and dismembering of
khashoggi he was a critic of the Saudi
Crown Prince and the de facto ruler
Holly Williams is in Saudi Arabia's
capital Riyadh and joins us this morning
Holly good morning to you good morning
this is the first official
acknowledgment from Saudi Arabia that
Gemara Shah jees body was dismembered
after he was killed inside the Saudi
Arabian consulate in Istanbul Turkey
though that is what Turkish officials
have been saying for weeks
according to Saudi Arabia's top
prosecutor the country's former deputy
head of intelligence a figure thought to
have been close to Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman gave an order for her shocked
Jew to be brought back to Saudi Arabia
by force if necessary
the reason was apparently his work for
foreign media but instead it's claimed
her shakti was given an anesthetic
injection that killed him that
contradicts a previous saudi statement
that he died in a fistfight remember
also that it took saudi arabia more than
two weeks to admit that her shoji had
been killed Saudi Arabia has come under
international pressure including from
the u.s. its most important ally to
explain how and why Jamal [ __ ] was
killed but today's statement still
doesn't tell us the names of the accused
their positions in the government or
tell us where Jamal has Shorty's body
ended up
bianna Holly Williams in Saudi Arabia
with that breaking news thank you